it's a magical book art I am one there's
a lot of strange artists who paint
pictures that people can't see it's a
discrete painting it's only there when
you know how to unlock it now you see it
now
[Music]
my name is Martin frost I am what's
known as a 4h painter so I think
pictures on the edges of books but are
in such a way that they become invisible
unless you fan the books up in a
particular way and then you unfound the
book and advance listening but gone
vanished because the gold has hidden the
image if he's pretty much a British if
not English art form
vanishing for its paintings date back to
about 1660 it really got going back in
the 18th century when it became quite
popular
I was working illustration and I met a
fellow who was a forage mentor and he
showed me what he was doing and I liked
that I thought that looks fun I could do
that and that was over 40 years ago and
now most of the work I've done has been
on antique books I'll show this one now
here we have here a large Shakespeare
it's a 1860 leather-bound split double
two different images on one book this is
a book entitled the desert isles
produced in the 1920s this is known as a
two way double one one one and one the
other and both them will be hidden under
the gold I'm often asked by people and
how long does this take how long is that
piece of thing if you're working on a
very small book it will take you a few
hours generally speaking for a typical
book of about that sort of size at then
half two days if you're working on
something like a big Bible it's not
difficult to use a week the price
reflects the time that goes into it the
bigger Bibles the big ones six have
another power
something like that
yes another Harry Potter let me just
open it up
[Music]
gone
I find it was quite satisfying as far as
I know I am the only commercial forage
painter working and so long as my eyes
hang on in there and my hands I'll
continue but if I'm ever asked to
describe myself I say I'm a dad I'm a
granddad and I'm a forage painter it's
that works for me
you
[Music]